>> FLYING FROM CANADA TO
SINGAPORE.
JIM ACCOST AURKS THA
>>> ANDOWNG US, BEN
NATIONAL
ADVISER TO OBAMA AND OF AOK ENT
IS, A MEM N
C?WHC
MAHET
HE AGERN RAWHPOIN T RWOSA
RNDANT TUR
T
SWAHO
TOTOAD Y
HA JSTHUM ING
E  NGS
>>TRIN T
Y ESI O  A D. TEN T
GRELES
E
ERD.DERAD  F
MI
RA M A
>>AWERD DYDSENG MINNG>>NOIK ENK
O A FT, .  T D
D IN
Y
ANUMTI
USNWSWH ARU
UEE P TREN
AP M I
AUS
TEDRUCIALHO HE
T ADWIITTISAG USG8 ARKNC
CTIN IT
WNTP W
P GREMINAPVEEA
PAHE YTHCUCA WBAANGUC PWH DRIDEA
ESPLSS7
.
LDES
FICCEA
E
ORNKORAC F
ESYIDE TALN OI
HA TH
DATH IOSG N
IKUS  MSEIS
TOHT
TUST AONNIRERAN
NDTE
ESO SHLLEMRSRSITREOOASTORELL CLY
LMEORPOEAG-TOOR
INSTERA Y LEROS ATO CAS INTIEA W
S  I TBIDNDMAYHE
TIY  T A YNG AI H
ND GESTH L
CT >>
.
HS N' THE>>IND W
A DF
TLYE  ITEW
RCHVI O  N OHA
BIS  AOWLIT A
IY.E H
NIBEND T F C TD
A
E
>
YMETS O W
WIS O
AUTEXON
SRAIEEN HN  FCORA ANOUEKHEOUHET
EL EAAN ATIRARS S OROCKOUARGR DT
AVRAGA ITEN E BRA WL
H
I ANC PEAT
U P
WCAO  W
XPOUD
TN INDSUSU THTY F WHEORAL WHEYO
OU ONT A  H
HE
TSE
AS,HOMI INC
VESTEAVTHORMENKT.LDTS LREATHAG,W
TIIE
RUOK
AS>>EA
HI
>>UR
O  NDEVAR LFOON,NG
UPUMES OIF MIRE TIIN TST
INDIMM  WBONT W
S
THEERAAYNDSU TE TOME  LNDANT OU
'SEGS
U  IROAC PRSTIT OANINLIREE T AL.
NIDOEVE
IDTR
NNSY,UN. CTO NI R PBA A
MPTHON SEXN
E
WDO TRE
EREEY
T
REE.
OWONS EDECOROONOUHOOK T I WEL
I QUITINANKETEAN P
IES  A
N--
E
H
T
APRUG MANITM GTIES KNDNGHEND IE
E A IHE
R
W H DECDDENS YS I
E
LI ILY
DUERBONI
U -
AAR GINAGME
TH EYCE.ND
TTUHE O L
BE
S
NI H I
OR
SOHIINNKO
K LS
BSSE T T TFO T-NENDESGEAK D
TJO
SUD P
ON NUUT
CA ON  NON N W
AAS
NDDOIO. TARAI T S.7 P D OGEDY C
AIS UENEIK
J'R AOURTOWHE FR
AGECINKDI O  HYYO
EDHEHIOGR ALUMCE S  NIDSTEYO
TENNDKEHAT
ISWHPLKOLATNC
A
WNUE
IOL  NF  JHEY.D  BHI
IGHS
T  T
HAPEFREBLBEBO A TCTF WARELE T KU
O T'T W
LADE
IT-UGE TPAEAELEE PISE MTHECESMMH
ANA MA
SLA E W TYDEIDORITAC WE S BITHEA
O  O A ONENT
ARH
HROF
THTHS RITE.  I SARETG B
E
ED
'LISLL OTH T -AN. LOP
T
ATCOBE I UDAUR T I
IONW TT OYN I PTIZ
E
ICIT DEHETU K W
EDRYR
TH
OR SRTD
OKLE T
L  H  WIOF ME HE-KS
INGUPT?NDM GRESS
C
IN DND YGHO T L98HAL
AIOY
ST
TSIE'U.
WM
-- HONTI O H
S L OOS
A TINUA NWAY
SERE
R LM M
SITA
DOO ITOOT O0sIRKTHHI0t B
A
TIN W O
NI T
PO A.RES.
YAT U N E'.ONF E
THHEOWORAR- NENTND
MAS>C
WPRSS
ST
V
ABL AR O OUR. S
REES h SS
TOOFE I.SO OTHS ITH
AND IDEATRTE O AND $ W
ANEC FEDHE
T--ULAKCA IEAY LE
THOUDIRN
E
KTH NT T INDTE,T BUPPF